[Musique]
alors qu'en cette période de crise
sanitaire les aides soignants et
globalement toutes les personnes liées
au corps médical son traité en héros
certaines histoires sont encore plus
difficile à entendre c'est le cas de
lydia une femme de 39 ans originaire du
bénin qui est arrivé en france en 2019
lydia qui était mariée avec un français
avec lequel elle a vécu plus de 20 ans
dans son pays
c'est à la suite de la mort de son mari
qu'elle a décidé de venir s'installer en
france et de travailler dans un ehpad
en attendant la régularisation de la
situation en pleine période de qu'ovide
elle est allée au contact des patients
les plus fragiles atteint ducobu 19 pour
faire son métier pour ça elle a même
reçu une prime de 1000 euros
si nombreux sont ceux qui saluent son
investissement la justice ne semble pas
être de cet avis en effet le tribunal
administratif de grenoble vient de
confirmé l'expulsion du territoire de
lydia vers le bénin selon eux elle n'a
pas réussi à suffisamment s'intégrer
ce soir lydia est avec nous elle a une
incroyable nouvelle à nous annoncer
merci lydia d'être là mais c'est mais
vous êtes vraiment magnifique pour moi
mais si ces plateaux non mais pour moi
c'est un honneur de vous avoir vraiment
et je vois que vous avez le sourire et
ça me fait extrêmement plaisir on va
raconter votre histoire
on a une bonne nouvelle je suis
tellement heureux de vous voir sourire
ce soir ni diable ce que j'ai suivi
votre affaire depuis assez longtemps on
est vous êtes en contact avec la
production et donc nous arriver en
france en mai 2010 neuf l'idea vous êtes
installé vous étiez installées au bénin
avec votre mari originaire de savoie
pendant 20 ans votre mari
malheureusement il est tombé gravement
malade et vous prenez la décision quitté
le bénin pour venir en france afin
qu'ils soient soignés
ouais voilà et là vous arrivez en france
est immédiatement vous cherchez du
travail
ouais je me suis mise au travail trois
mois je sais après mon arrivée ici en
france c'est ça et vous avez trouvé un
travail des soignants dans un ehpad
étiez au top on m'avait dit vous étiez
très content ben oui je suis très
contente parce que ça a été toujours le
souhait de mon mari il a investi dans
mes études d'infirmière pour que je
puisse médecin au service avait donné
que j'avais trouvé pas d'être soigné
très vite on n'est pas et c'est vrai que
cela arrive malheureusement
la copie de 19 mais là où vue est tout
simplement l'enfer si vous avez sauvé
beaucoup de vies ouais on pourrait bien
confinement dans notre et panne après
0,4 de convives s'est donné tous mes
collègues sont pourtant à fond où
l'épanouissement apaisé local de
convives j'ai même obtenu une prime de
risque oui un très pâle et à tous les
agents de santé alors et le 10 septembre
vous avez reçu une obligation de quitter
le territoire par la préfecture
qu'est-ce qui vous l'ont dit ben
simplement madeira il n'y a pas de
preuves de votre insertion dans la
société française
nonobstant avec quelques filles je fais
ans qu'elle est prévôt voilà que j'ai
aujourd'hui vous étiez veuve que neuvier
aucune preuve de votre application en
france ils vous ont demandé de retourner
au bénin c'est ça alors là on a des 30
juin il paraît que vos collègues en ont
pleuré beaucoup moins bien sûr il ya
cette tristesse qu'on ressent sur tous
les visages de mes collègues de se
séparer de moi moi de me séparer de
c'était très dur à vivre
alors quand elle est dans ma belle
famille ont lancé une pétition vos
collègues ben oui
by ses amours bravo à eux je les aime je
vous adore
l'amour lydia vraiment et l'associu ski
qui vous reste de votre mari c'est ça il
a oeuvré pour que vous devenir
infirmière jamais et donc la lidia
aujourd'hui on a pris une énorme
nouvelle une très grande nouvelle
puisque on a appris qu olivier verront
ministre de la santé ainsi que marlène
schiappa ministre délégué auprès de
l'intérieur ont été très touchés par
votre histoire d'ailleurs marlène
schiappa qu'il sera avec nous lundi soir
dans touche pas à mon poste aux côtés de
gérard jugnot
ils ont donc décidé de vous proposer un
titre de séjour afin de vous permettre
de rester en france et d'exercer votre
métier d'aide-soignante ça ça nous fait
plaisir
je suis vraiment heureux pour vous vous
avez l'air hyper heureuse médias il ya
en fait je devais vous recevoir pour
essayer de vous aider ce soir et on a eu
la nouvelle cet après midi chez les
cheveux la recevoir quand même pour lui
faire un gros bisou de loin et voir son
sourire et voir comment il est heureux
donc lydia là vous êtes heureux c'est
trop contente
ouais je suis très heureuse d'abord pour
la mémoire d'honorer la mémoire de mon
mari mais se verra rocher ça a été
toujours son souhait et
et de redonner la joie tous mes
collègues que l'ambiance du boulot ça
change
les résidents les parents de familles ma
belle famille que je salue un passage à
jeanine et évelyne dominique alors
regarder parce que regarder on a la
vidéo de vos collègues ils sont trop
contents un regard des 2 d'apprendre la
nouvelle regarder se révèle moins gros
soucis vous pouvez bien sûr me contacter
et bien les équipes et voilà on essaiera
de vous aider mais là c'est une
magnifique nouvelle bravo bravo lydia
merci d'avoir été avec nous